the speaker no problem we married my
still colleague Jill Gundam design it up
okay thanks very much so I'm going to
talk about some work but erson I've been
doing for the last few years and it's
been to test a rather strange hypothesis
that some kind of evolution goes on in
your brain so we basically proposed that
there are replicators in your brain so
this is very speculative of course it's
a hypothesis on its we're doing
exploration in this we propose their
replicators in your brain and that they
evolve by natural selection as you think
and sleep and they allow open-ended
thought by the generation selection of
units in your brain and why do we have
this crazy idea well we suspect it's
true because of a convergence of
implementation and algorithmic arguments
and we're testing this hypothesis now in
three domains of abstraction as animal
level so actually looking to see whether
things could replicate in your brain
whether there could be units revolution
at the cognitive level to try and fit
human behavior to evolutionary models
and the constructive level to see if we
can make robots that use evolution in
their controllers in order to produce
open-ended behavior in some sense so
she's too polite to say this but frankly
we were annoyed by Gerald Adelman
because Gerald Adelman has a theory
called neural Darwinism which is not
Darwinian at all in fact he's probably
held the theory of neural Darwinism
backed by some decades so we after a
careful reading of Adelman there's no
replicators no units of evolution know
things that multiply with variation and
heredity in his theory and so we would
thought it worthwhile to ask whether
there could be actual units of evolution
in the brain why because natural
selection is now Griffin that's capable
of the accumulation of adaptation making
a copy is actually useful in search
because the print
the duplication and divergence means you
don't lose the original so when you
change something you can always get back
and so I summarize it like this the idea
of the evolution of ability like this
that the watchmaker is blind but he's
not stupid so what I mean by that is
that I'm one of the people that believes
that evolution gets better over time
that it's able to improve its quality of
search now I know that evolution doesn't
look ahead but neither dude great chess
player so ready was asked how many moves
do you look ahead he said one the right
one so he does that by perceptual
chunking right he doesn't and then he
spends 15 mid 20 minutes just checking
that his actual move is correct so
that's the kind of insight that I think
evolution has because it has an
experience of even though it's blind it
has experience so that there's a fine I
think there's a gradient between
sophisticated inductive cognition and
blind random expiration also in terms of
cognitive architectures we need to have
something that can accumulate adaptation
be able to solve many tasks use what
it's learnt in the past to solve new
task the machine learning we don't have
that frankly there's no machine learning
algorithm that can you would wish to
leave on for ten years and it would
continue to get better over time so
these are the some of the the reasons
we're actually exploring this now at a
project with Kevin steris and Sussex
who's actually got fetal rat neuron
cultures and we're trying to basically
do seeding experiments and that to see
what can be copied so that's um just
examine what natural selection is first
so John Maynard Smith defines natural
selection as a an algorithm I think it's
actually a class of algorithms that
takes place when you have the following
properties you have units of evolution
these are things which multiply there's
variation which means that a is
different from be and there's heredity
so the offspring of a resemble a more
than they resemble be so this is a class
of algorithms in the sense that it can
be implemented in many substrate so just
as it's implemented in the immune system
to some extent we're wondering can it be
implemented in
brain so I've sonnet examine carefully
ax a two different definitions of
natural selection which possibly explain
why Adelman has called his theory neural
Darwinism so price defines a process
which Adelman may have equated with
natural selection which is one where if
there's a covariance between a trait and
the probability of its transmission then
you'll have that trait increasing in in
frequency in the population but this
applies to many things in fact price in
his paper says it even applies the
tuning of radios so that's not oops
that's not what I what John Maynard
Smith means by natural selection so they
may give an example to me got the
classification here which I want to
explore so consider solitaire search
stochastic hillclimb you've got one
robot or 11 agent on it on a hillside
and it basically does stochastic hill
climbing I call that solitaire search
okay so a stupid fairly stupid thing to
do would be to do parallel independent
solitaire search and that would give you
some speed up so these robots don't
communicate with each other there's no
transmission of information and they'll
have a slightly higher probability of
getting to a global optimum so that's
parallel independent a solitary search
next we can have competitive learning
competitive learning is where you have
multiple search points but you give more
exploration resources to the search
points that are currently higher up so
the equations the this multiplicative
stuff that we're talking about earlier
is falls into that that's a selection
'used algorithm that's not natural
selection natural selection happens when
you have many search points but there's
actually recruitment so that things that
are currently higher app reconfigure
matter in other places in order to be
more like itself there's actually
information transmission what's
transmitted here is the X is the
position of the robot of the solution in
space so that should information
transfer in space so that's actually
we consider to be a subset of algorithms
which are natural selection according to
john maynard smith informally particle
filters particle swarm optimization the
immune system journey natural selection
and genetic algorithms fall into this
class so it's a class where there is
actually information transfer in space
and that's certainly a subset of the
things that price is talking about and
it's a the subset of things we're
exploring in in the brain okay another
reason we find this important to look at
is that there's a deep relationship
between Bayesian inference and natural
selection so here's Bay's equation and
there's the replicator equation so we
see that the the frequency of something
in the population the relative frequency
is something in the population can be
thought of as the probability of that
hypothesis in generation T and
generation T plus 1 the posterior could
be thought of as the frequency of the
that variant in the population and the
likelihood can be thought of as its
fitness so this is interesting because
in cognitive science the Bayesian
framework for induction is becoming very
popular and we basically proposed that
natural selection is an efficient way of
implementing approximate bayesian
inference in the brain so okay so this
is all very this is that our kind of
motivation why we think we're not
completely mad so this leaves so but
what the hell can replicate in your
brain so we're trying to work out models
that are plausible so we want to work
out we don't know is the answer and so
what we're doing is trying to come up
with various things that could replicate
in your brain and so here's our first
attempt so the idea is that here is that
a pattern of connectivity could
replicate in your brain so here neuron B
is connected near on seeing your own
beers connected in Iran a right that's a
pattern of connectivity and the idea is
that if a topographic map can be
achieved
then some kind of inference process in
another region of the brain can observe
the spikes happening in this part of the
brain and reconstruct that pattern of
connectivity okay that's the first idea
so we wrote a model about that in 2008
and sorry yep
yeah yeah so basically physicists have
rediscovered natural selection in that
literature so what happened so basically
population MCFC particle filters these
are formally equivalent to the algorithm
that John Maynard Smith is talking about
so that we actually found that extremely
interesting the the problems that they
face and still of the problems that
evolutionary computation face is how to
do it how to make a good proposal
distribution in order be able to they
also want to sample the distribution but
we want to maximize something there's so
there's slightly different motivations
in the two fields but they are very
deeply related so just to go to this in
a bit more detail we've got a paper that
came out recently that actually I think
makes much nicer model above about this
and it's quite what I like about it is
but the copying that we propose of
patterns of connectivity in the brain
actually occurs by causal inference this
part of brain observes the pattern of
spontaneous activity in this puddle
brain and in furs the connectivity
pattern that would have caused it and
that's nice because that same mechanism
can explain how that part of the brain
does causal inference about the world
events in the world so one of the things
we've done is to explain the experiments
of Alison Gopnik with blick it's on
causal inference and children I assume
that people hit really care much about
causal inference and children so I'm not
going to talk about it in great detail
unless people want me to afterwards but
I'll just go into the Houthis copying
works briefly so the idea is that has
anybody who's heard of spike
time-dependent plasticity hands up okay
so spike time-dependent last icity is an
asymmetric heavy and learning rule which
works like this if a presynaptic neuron
fires before a postsynaptic one then the
weight of that connection goes up but if
the postsynaptic neuron fires before the
presynaptic one then the weight of the
collection actually goes down right so
it's inferring a very simple kind of
causality might be not causality because
something else might have caused both
these things to fire at different times
but it's a it's a
a guess based on a heuristic of temporal
differences so what we've got is a
mechanism that has three plasticity
rules which can infer these kinds of
causal networks and the three plasticity
rules our spy can be depended plasticity
very interesting Lee its multiplicative
so that multiplicative nature is exactly
the same as the multiplicative major we
were looking at earlier there's a couple
of rules that say if there's a
postsynaptic spiking no presynaptic
spike really reduce the weight and if
there's presynaptic spike and no person
acted spike you reduce the weight as
well and that implements a and then
there's something that implements the
rascal of agna rule which has been
implementing the hetero surendra
competition them basically what this
means is that it it explains a couple of
things in causal inference called
backwards blocking and screening off so
don't to go to the details of that but
basically if you implement these
plasticity rules then we've shown that
I'll skip this bit if we implement these
plasticity rules we've shown that we can
copy various structures of what all the
possible structures actually of a three
node system and this can trivially
generalized to a larger system if you
allow activity not to spread so we can
infer the temporal and we can be further
delays between these things as well so
this is one method by which a certain
super synaptic organization a unit of
information in the brain that's more
than just once I naps could be copied
from one part of the brain to another
this is actually what we're trying to
test with Kevin's fetal rat neuron so
you take them you take the pregnant rat
kill it take its fetuses brains out and
solubilize them and put them in a on a
microelectrode array and then you
stimulate them with a pattern of
activity that would have been produced
by one causal Network and then you
observe the spontaneous activity and see
if it's able to entrain that spontaneous
activity and then see if you can copy
that into another dish we've just about
got there the fetal rat neurons working
in addition we can stimulate them now so
I can't we don't know it's obviously not
going to work so what we need to do is
to basically iterate we've we spent two
years going the grant to do that and now
we can actually in our experiments we
find our models and do more
so that's one approach okay so that's
one thing that can replicate yup ah
sorry yes okay right so this is it this
is a weight matrix of from and to and
this is the the pattern that where this
is the network that we're trying to copy
and so these these black dots indicate
where the weights are high so what's
been copied is so we've got it basically
a network here and okay what happens is
this we have a weakly connected network
at the top fully connected week and we
randomly stimulate with sparse
activation this network so what happens
is if you stimulate this neuron here
very shortly afterwards there'll be a
spike here and a spike there right so
these neurons will spike slightly after
that one so according to spike
time-dependent plasticity what will
happen is that the the strength of that
connection strength of that connection
will increase a bit but but there will
be a false if there's a different if
there's a different delay here there'll
be a false positive inference of the
connection like that or that depending
on how you the delays are sorted out so
the extra rules that we've got are
designed to basically deal with these
false positive and negative inferences
that happen so it's basically this this
network has this plasticity rule set of
plastic jewels is observing the spikes
from this one and is reconstructing
these patterns of connectivity that but
not exactly there are some errors so if
it's stochastic then there's always
going to be some errors and the in the
copying here so that's that's what yes
so that's yeah but we have the rule that
typically what happens is for this to
fire you need both activity from here
and from there for that to fire so
that's there are some details like that
that are required for that for this
copying to work well that's the idea
that you can copy patterns of
connectivity from one part
into another okay so that's something
that could happen in the order of a
minute so that's quite slow in a way so
here's another idea this is a bit weird
this is the idea is that you can
actually have oops the idea is that you
could actually have units of evolution
embedded in a in a network so here we
have a network and there's two possible
flows through this network like that or
like that so these are paths and in this
network where there are more possible
part so in this network there's a
there's a path there's a part there's a
path and there's a part for possible
paths through this network and each of
those parts has certain probability of
being taken and in it we've been able to
show that this is actually so his
example said his activity that goes down
one path and this is actually formally
equivalent to a unit of evolution so a
mutation is a bypass at an alternative
route through that path through that
Network and if that is fitter than that
will survive and the original will be
destroyed so this is actually formally
equivalent to a loop to locust to our
model that's what I've described there
so the frequence we've got so you take a
path that path has a certain producers a
certain reward and that reward
reinforces that path in proportion to
its the reward and parts which have more
reward have a higher probability of
producing mutations so it turns out then
that we're basically implementing a
genetic algorithm in a in a network but
what's interesting about this system is
the parts actually overlap so when you
change one part you're influencing the
genotypes of all the the other parts
that share that component to the part so
it's interesting Lee different also from
a genetic algorithm does it satisfy John
Maynard spits the notion of even units
revolution well if you are producing
offspring and it's exactly identical to
you then there's no explicit
multiplication it's just strengthening
but if your offspring is different
then there is a new part and the
different only the difference between
you and your offspring is represented by
the bypass so what it means is that you
actually are maintaining a population of
solutions in this network where you're
only evaluating one solution as a time
so it's a kind of halfway house between
proper natural selection where you can
have simultaneous evaluation of all the
population at the same time but you do
actually maintain many solutions so
we've tried this out on a range of
combinatorial optimization problems one
of the in some cases it does better in
some cases does worse than a standard GA
some nice properties are for example
that if you have many different
environments so here's two environments
just wanted the old ones in the old
zeros problem and we're flipping that
environment at regular intervals that's
the ga in in red and our system over
over a while can actually adapt faster
to the the problem big as that solution
the old paths still remains in the
network so here's the is the part for
the all zeros and your ones so we've
also tried on things like the riches
hiss problem and it's able to do quite
well in that so I'm so here's one kind
of implementation of natural selection
in a rather weird way we've got
genotypes overlapping organisms don't
overlap with each other typically but
here we are unit to be pollution cam so
hello right right well Richard well you
should all come to Richard's talk on
Friday they go home he's going to talk
about the hip in detail but it's
basically a problem that he invented
which is a problem which produces a
really pathological fitness landscape
with lots of local Optima basically got
to the two best solutions either all
ones or zeros and it's a hierarchical
problem so it has structure you've got
basically look at pairs of adjacent low
side if they're both one or both zero
then that produces the one at the next
level but if they're a zero and one then
that produces a zero the next level and
then you keep doing that and you scale
it for different level so it's a it say
he made it up
and didn't you yeah yeah frightening for
he invented Friday uh-huh it stands for
hierarchical if and only if you can
think of it as a hierarchical parity
functional okay yep so what we've said
okay so I've been talking about two
kinds of copying the copying of patterns
of creativity and the copying of parts
of activation through a structure which
is formally equivalent to a population
another thing you can do is to think
about patterns of bistable neural
activation that's being copied so if you
have a set of neurons then they can be
by stable on or off and you can copy
that you can basically implements
something like a one plus one evolution
of strategy so you copy this to another
set of neurons with with some mutation
you do that for a while and then what
Richard discovered is that if you have a
bit of heavy and learning and he'll
probably talk about this if you have a
bit of heavy and learning going on then
what happens is actually you learn off
diagonal weights and that means that
when you do copying again you actually
are learning basically linkage between
these adults so you're copying becomes a
non-random and and so we were very happy
with that because it means that
potentially natural selection of brain
could be more powerful than genetic
natural selection because there are all
kinds of learning algorithms that can be
used to structure or expiration
distribution in ways that genetic would
find hard now that principle is
something but we've been extending
recently so here we're learning
basically a covariance matrix and it
turns out that you can actually learn
much more complicated and interesting
models about the kinds of the structure
of the fitness landscape so what we will
be doing this this is also the hit 158
bit what we do here is to train
something called a denoising auto encode
which is
neural network on the best bit of the
population the best sample of the
population so far and we trained it so
that it takes one of those individuals
the genotypes apply some noise to it and
tries to reconstruct the original so it
basically trains it to find the best
part of the population from a larger
basin of attraction and we're using
single-layered denoising auto encoders
but the potential is we can use a deeper
system so by combining supervised
learning in order to try and learn the
structure of the space with stochastic
optimization we hope you will to improve
on those algorithms I think we're going
to be discovering soon but trying to
discover how evolution can learn
structure is an important beautiful is
an important principle so it just play
the video so this is a system evolving
to basically discover the his problem so
okay okay so this is all quite abstract
to the moment so I propose three
different kinds of things that could
replicate in the brain patterns of
connectivity patterns of activity and
pathways probably there are others so
what's the evidence for any kind of
replication the brain well replication
is different from copying right there's
lots of copying in my computer but
there's no replication yep because to
have replication you have to copy the
probability of being transmitted as well
so I can give an example of copying in
the brain at least and that is a if you
take a cat and cut a part of its retina
route and you look at the cells in its
visual primary visual cortex then that
area of cortex that is not that is no
longer receiving inputs those cells went
far anymore and they'll become very
sensitive and if you have spiked
time-dependent plasticity this is
described in this paper if you're spike
time-dependent plasticity what will
happen is one of those the orientation
selectivity of those cells will copy the
orientation selectivity of one of the
adjacent cells
in v1 and that's nice it doesn't
actually completely confirm a
replication because the show replication
you have to show that when this copies
from back then the probability of that
being copied somewhere else is put is
proportional to that it's come how
covariant with that trait right so we
have to we're not sure whether that's an
example but recently there's a paper by
kill guard about cortical map plasticity
where he actually says that the way that
neural regions like for example in taxi
drivers the bit of the brain that's
responsible for representing streets in
London grows and adding birds in spring
a bit of the brain that's responsible
for singing enlarges so there's there's
the there's the growth and shrinkage of
these cortical areas and so the question
is and then what happens is this is
doing some kind of search and then
there's a rican traction of the the
representation you don't have to have
this larger area the larger area is
large because it's increasing its
effective population size and then it
shrinks again and the right solution is
is there so that principle of cortical
map plasticity there's a beautiful
nature in the auditory cortex kill
guards the auditory cortex which we're
trying now to model so we need to have
more realistic models of the cortex and
how copying could be implemented in the
back through spike time-dependent
plasticity but this gives us some data
we can look at right so that's the first
part about implementations the second
part is to try and actually get to see
okay so I've described how there might
be replicated in the brain you know it's
worth looking at and so the question now
is what kind of algorithmic advantages
could replicators in your brain give you
that we don't have the capacity to
explain already so
a lot of this data is I think gonna come
from child development how children are
able to accumulate adaptations over time
during infancy so one of the things
we've been looking at is can we so we
had so this is a hard problem now it not
only are we try to find replicates in
the brain which we haven't found we are
also trying to explain how these
replicators could produce function so we
want to explain the we want to do we
want to discover the the hereditary
substrate and discover the whole
principles of the development in one go
so that's obviously quite hard so one of
the principles that we have is that
natural selection is able to do search
it's sparse search over the symbolic
spaces so in cognitive science there's a
bit of a fight between the symbol
systems people in the connection is all
right the symbol systems people like
Gary Marcus and third or and others they
say that cognition requires
compositionality and systematicity which
basically means that there's something
like molecules in there things that can
make connections with each other in
lawful ways and in which the structure
determines the function but just like in
a molecule dfp its function will be a
lawful configuration function of its the
atoms of the way the atoms connected so
that's really required for
open-endedness that nobody knows how to
implement that in neural networks and
we've got some ideas about that but this
level of description here is a
computational level of description so as
well as cooked in neuronal models we try
to do computational models which include
natural selection so these kinds of
control is that we're evolving so this
is like a bag this whole thing is the
unit of evolution and we're evolving
basically pack graphs so it's a bit like
genetic programming but it's not because
all these units are could be neural
networks and this could be a Zika which
think this would be a seat erm this
could be any learning at any basically
any chapter in the machine
textbook again that could be implemented
one of yous and these things of how the
messages are passed between units so we
were doing direct policy search so
that's typically what people do NE
volusia nary computation which is just
you evolve stuff and there's the century
put going in the controls the majors
going out so that's one of the things we
try to do and one of the other
motivations that makes us the experiment
i'm going to show you is that we didn't
want to put in an explicit fitness
function we didn't want to say when you
have a child the child does does
something called play the child doesn't
get any explicit reward from that the
child has intrinsic motivation so
there's cut some kind of low-dimensional
task independent fitness function but
the child has two segments behavior
that's not dependent on external reward
and there's a whole field of people
looking at this intrinsic motivation so
what is the child trying to maximize
when he put it in the Jolly Jumper
Esther thelen says its balance per ounce
so what does that mean so there's people
are saying but for example children
might want to maximize the first
derivative of printability it autumn
Aksumite predictability otherwise this
is very predictable looking so you want
it but you want to maximize the first
derivative predictability what
predictable increasing Schmidt ariba
says you want to maximize the first
derivative compressibility he says that
beauty is compressibility and the
interestingness is the first degree of
difficulty there's all fuzzy species of
ideas about what you want to maximize
that it's coming up in the literature
nobody knows exactly what the
dimensional so the value is the really
maximized but undoubtedly must exist so
another thing is you might want to
maximize variants in the population
because under some ridiculous
assumptions that might increase the rate
of fitness increase so there are lots of
things that you might want to maximize
in order to improve the quality of
search and the brave because it's been
evolved as a unit can develop ways of
actually improving itself that's an even
Mary system so problem here is if it has
to be something which is try to maximize
rather than to some dynamics yes thing
is if Australia maxima something well I
think that I think that we have where
well it doesn't have to be of course but
I think that we are entities which have
values and values are things we try to
maximize and each of us is different in
that we have a very unique set of values
I mean no to people's values are exactly
the same there's a comment or explosion
of possible values and that's largely
what determines our uniqueness that's
why it's sad when something dies but you
can't really me construct that for a
unique subset of values that they had it
doesn't really matter with Lee forget
list of the things what makes them them
is their next to the value so with with
those maximization things we're trying
to maximize we don't know how we develop
these things so the what we did we
totally ignore that question because
it's actually very hard to develop an
algorithm that Co evolves that well
fundamentally I think we have to develop
the cognitive architecture right and we
don't know what that cognitive
architecture is but I think it should be
something like you have evilution of
policies you have the volition of models
and you have evolution of values and
these these three things interact in
some way and that's probably what's
happening in our brain but I don't know
more than that so this is what we did
anyway so
so this is a sort of example of a fairly
standard example from evolutionary
robotics but where we're using this this
this architecture that I talked about so
we've got a nail in a jolly jumper we
started off in the morning so this is
run evolution for about six hours over
the course of the day so that we've just
randomly initialized population of
controllers for the robot and the
fitness function we fix we don't allow
it to evolve that we try to but there's
a scaling issue because you have a value
you've got to try it out for some time
and see how much you're progressing on
that value before you can try another
valued and then you have to select so
there's a hierarchical selection
processes the evolution of values is all
the remained to slower than 2 g's
illusion the policies in the frame of we
had so that problem needs to be solved
nobody knows how many kovol values and
things to do so their behavior of the
robot it's in there for about six hours
in total there's the thickness of the
robot over time oh sorry the fitness
function is to maximize the first route
will visit Zed accelerometer so we just
fixed that it's just try to back to
maximize bats we didn't put the per
ounce in the perhaps it would have been
maximizing the songs are divided by the
motor energy here it got its foot stuck
on the cushion so the fitness went down
and all those things die but were and
then it had to readapt to that the foot
being stuck on the cushion there it's
redacted
it's actually using it's about from
closed-loop control if using the force
sensitive resistors on its feet to push
off we did mean we did a test just in a
moment to test that it's called removal
of cushion his behavior is quite changes
it was a cushion dependent I said that
there's a units of evolution die-off
that now we're cushion depended on the
cushion the independent units of
evolution are now replicating better
hey so this goes on and this is what's
this
so it's quite trivial its discovery the
resonant frequency of the baby bouncer
now what we need to do is to obviously
the whole point of the algorithm is that
we can now store that structure that
representation and evolve more and more
behavior that uses the all the kinds of
skills that it's learned to then be able
to do more and more schools we don't
quite know how to do that but that's
what's required the ability to
accumulate adaptations over multiple
tasks and that's what label is cheap
developmental robotics that there's been
millions of pounds worth of investment
into robotics nobody has solved the
problem of how to accumulate adaptation
and that's really where we believe that
some kind of ensemble method that
because this is the l'ensemble method
that is illusionary is required in
conjunction with standard machine
learning so that's so we've got we've
got to improve that cognitive
architecture so there's several levels
of investigation another aspect is
language right so how do we learn
language and as time has gone on we've
moved people moving obviously from more
of a Chomsky Universal grammar idea
where there's no search to something
where more search is allowed so the
problem was that search is very
difficult and the best work on this is
by Luke steals who's been looking at
fluid construction Graham and this is
where basically constructions are
computational units that trans form
meanings into utterances and utterances
into meanings and these constructions
are actually inferred during child
development and his [ __ ] bradley tale
model of this and it's fundamentally an
ignition remodel there's evolution of
these constructions there's population
of them and they produce new
constructions with various and so we
were trying to work out a at a
computation level how this thing works
and whether
evolutionary principles can be included
in that so some issues thinking in this
way is a different perspective it allows
you to ask questions like do things like
I Gonzalez hold apply the brain and does
that explain the differences between
other species and us and all kinds of
issues about diversity maintenance and
so forth so so we're basically looking
at this from different angles and so I
think I'll leave it leave it there and
leave some time for questions so i have
a question which is how many replicators
can I fit in my brain is that enough to
do anything mmm I don't know we are
models are not at that level of
predictive ability yet I think when we
start modeling the the kilghard result
of auditory cortex that we will be able
to say things like that but I can't say
yet one of the you can have things like
the liters of you see you can have it
it's going to be more like an
evolutionary algorithm is it doesn't
have to be constrained by exactly the
same principles within the genetic
evolution and so I think one of the yeah
so much wrong just that my impression is
that equation is slow with rather
inefficient part where I thinking is
hopefully a little bit more issues in
the revetments so well me that's
interesting so I think that I've
completely forgot to talk about modeling
human Commission so for example you can
actually look at the time complexity of
with the only way to work out I think
whether an algorithm is being done in
the brain on artist look at how the time
it takes to solve a problem scales with
the size of that problem and that's what
we're beginning to do so one of the is
so these are in tasks or inside task so
for example here's the mind no problem
you have to join these nine dots by four
lines without removing on paper the
paper right so there you generate ideas
and you select ideas and many people
can't solve this in in days so if it
wasn't celebrating half an hour so
there's a distribution of times the
solution right so we can try model
processes that produce these times to
solution in inside problems and look at
how be how that's working so that's one
approach that can be taken greedy
actually comes if you're talking about
the time for them so if i look at
thinking on a much much faster so visual
recognition tasks which one can do
things which are very high level
incredibly fast but between the time it
gets the brain when you've done it yeah
100 milliseconds and they're the lease
presumably some hierarchy of complexity
of visual recognition tasks before as I
know no one is really studied at least
not systematically as far as the time
that takes us to do them or what it
might it very formal okay and though
that the advantage there so far not much
time for feedback and other aspects that
has goals that husbands that has been
studied say visual search has been
studied that it's quite clear that
there's some kind of parallel chunking
model that explains most there's two
kinds of search one way you can do it in
parallel one what we need two more
serial process it depends all the
discrimination is generally made its
categorization it's it's like for
example finding an L in lots of distract
a tease I kind of like whether a picture
of animal owners oh I see okay all right
but I don't think that so that kind of
process is not going to be one where
we're not saying the metra selection
which is quite and everything so that's
not it that's not gonna be a process of
search that's going to be a process
where you've got a financial selection
because you've got all the it could be a
process of some kind of competitive
learning have all the instances there
already you're and you're assigning
those are competing at very fast scale
for belief that's a different process to
what I'm suggesting which is a
stochastic exploration where you're
actually generating novel hypotheses and
besides a little early
what kind of things you are in the world
yeah as you're learning I thought this
might have more absolutely it's that
learning regular recognition hydrated
War I agree I agree so absolutely so
they just think I'm clarifying a host a
misunderstanding next question perhaps
the previous one is like I don't well
are you proposing that an evolutionary
process is bold thinking I don't think
you I then using with an evolution
process it easy old thing that evolving
how two things at runtime yeah so I'm
proposing that for example when you get
personal there's a nice page paper
called sleep its fires in sight I so I'm
proposing menu when you have a problem
and you go to sleep and you wake up in
the morning but natural selection has
been going on in your brain to solve
that problem its selection between
different ways of thinking sections
between solutions in a selection yeah so
that sort of thing should be the wrong
time in the selection amongst different
ways of running a thinking its path
within you're acquiring deductive
thinking doesn't I think induction where
you have to search in the space of
hidden causes required you could some
result sometimes if no no neural
networks until the identity problem so
there are some problems where you just
can't statistically calculate the
solution by observing the data you
actually have to have an idea some kind
of hidden cause has we hypothesize
Benzema tries to make sense of that data
and and then you've got to search for
hidden causes that's why doing science
is hard because you've got to make up
then causes the hypotheses that might
explain stuff and can't just directly
get from what seemed to the hypothesis
so you have to do some surgeon
alright
I find that occasionally helps his
daddy's arms oh yes I think they can cut
they gave up bouncing right and what's
the evidence that it improves that's
just it addicts have no longer doing
life for thinking without really change
right but apparently you're not adding
types that you can create all kinds of
other interconnections mmm cool that's
try later the general in the whole
regular primero coverage of natural
selection and nurture then you have a
population of related decaturville users
of sight and in solution detected for
pie or selection and fighting in dif
different
a knowledge I think there are going to
be well I think the selection functions
the criteria upon which replicator is
selected are going to be very
complicated and depending on which part
of the brain it's in I think it's very
interesting to look at well this I think
it's going to be interesting looking at
copying fidelity and how much
information can be evolved in the brain
I haven't thought specifically about
trivet that's worth looking at sometimes
we I mean yeah follow that I dreams into
recombination yes oh there's been lots
of that look this isn't a new idea and
it starts from William James everybody's
talk metaphorically about it lots of
people who talk metaphorically about
some kind of recombination so foreign
you know there are only a few people
that are actually trying to look at the
weather it could actually
mechanistically be implemented and as
you since you're being from football so
I guess there's a very inspired finding
in here from afford you the neuroscience
and from what I understand there was a
clear motivation
revolution but beyond that once you've
got some inspirations and their way of
thinking about it do I care very much
whether it's related we don't care I
should I sure why should I can go from
the understood so I think we the only
reason you should care is if this is the
only way to produce artificial
intelligence so that's one reason I
suppose if it's if this is going to help
us to construct the comment evocative so
they can actually produce that's one
reason yep the other reason is if it's
we need to actually produce that model
of the auditory cortex to make explicit
predictions if it's actually not
possible and then if it's possible that
we can use the whole everything we've
learned from me missionary biology all
that theoretical stuff we can apply to
neuroscience that's not an insignificant
thing to do you think is enough clear
understanding of things that that will
be useful beyond the inspiration I think
neither neuroscience or evolutionary
biology has all the answers but possibly
together they might have it more okay
thanks so much